I am really happy to be back in
Saskatoon I was happy to bring my son as
well we had a great week it's such a
great community here the the guys that
come to their workshops just to discover
these big Catholic families and these
very vibrant young men I was inducted
into the bowtie Society as you can see
by these fine young men over here so
we'll see how long that lasts but at
least while I'm in Saskatoon and I would
wear a bow tie so last year when I came
I talked about beauty and I talked about
the possibility of rest restoring beauty
in a world of ugliness and so this year
I was given the title of the fool how
the fool participates in the restoration
of culture and it's something that I've
been thinking about for quite a while
and so hopefully it's going to be very
different because now we're going to
talk about foolish things but hopefully
it will all in the end turn back towards
this restoration that we hope for when
we look around the world right now we
see some very strange things we if we're
attentive we notice that the world seems
to be drowning in folly drowning in even
an aesthetic of a kind of an ongoing
carnival this year or was it light it
was last year last year in Norwich
Cathedral in England they put this giant
helter-skelter carnival ride in the nave
of the church yes what that's exactly
how you should react to that and the
bishop gave a talk from the top of the
helter-skelter and at the end of the
talk he slid down the slide and just
came down to the end so the another
thing that happened this year as well is
they put a miniature golf in one of the
one of England's fine cathedrals when
medieval cathedrals and people could
come and play miniature golf inside the
Cathedral so what is happening why are
these things happening and on the other
hand we have something strange happening
on the other side so on the one hand we
have what used to be tradition what used
to be for formal culture politics it's
all becoming very clown esque and
there's this is this kind of strange
turning that we see but at the same time
we see people we see comedians we see
those who usually play the role of the
clown now starting to point out and to
flip things around for us so just a few
weeks ago there's a comedian his name is
Ricky Gervais he is a staunch atheist he
hates Christianity with a passion he is
very aggressive in his atheism
he's very mocking of Christianity but
adds a comic as someone who plays the
role of poking at the system what
happens when the system is upside down
what do you do what does the clown do
when the whole world is a carnival how
do you make someone laugh and the entire
world is a joke that's the world we're
living in and so what we're starting to
see is we're starting to see these these
these comedic characters start to point
out and so just a few weeks ago he gave
a speech at an award show in Hollywood
and in his speech he just he just ran
through these Hollywood characters he
just kept smashing at them you know
accusing them of all kinds of crazies
and choosing them being accomplices to
to the me2 movement yeah with Weinstein
accusing them of being a confidence of
Epstein and instead of Elia is like all
of this he was just going right after
them and it was just astounding to watch
and so now here's this guy this at this
atheist who in one day had 500,000 more
followers on Twitter and there were all
conservatives and Christians and all
these people and so here in his still
he's still a clown so he says you
probably can't read it
he says I've noticed a couple of tweets
criticizing me for accepting new
followers who are opposite of me
Christian conservative pro-life pro-gun
reactionaries says of course I accept
them to err is human to forgive divine
it's what Jesus would do they says dog
bless all my followers so still in the
fool in in the fools guys he flips it
upside down right because of course we
all know that dog is is the upside down
of God but nonetheless he now this fool
this 80's fool is the one who is
pointing out the failings of this clown
upside-down world that we're seeing
another example that has just happened
recently which is completely crazy Kanye
West who may be of you i if you don't
know who he is I'm happy for you I'm
very happy that if you don't always but
if you do he is a he's a rapper he's a
he's a very famous performer and he is
known for being a very extreme in his
behavior he does bring wild things he he
seeks he goes up and talks in front of
people when he's not supposed to and he
he's he's he said crazy things on TV and
he went insane he ended up in an asylum
just a few years ago all of this was
happening married Kim Kardashian who if
you don't know she is I even better I'm
really happy you don't you probably
sadly doing whole new cheers but he
married this very let's just say very
loose or very whatever that he married
someone a very strange lady but now all
of a sudden this guy he he in his
madness almost he converts to
Christianity and he completely flipped
around and so he is now trying to create
these events that are concerts but
they're they're not really concerts
almost like church services it's very
strange but he's saying things that no
one else can say he's criticizing
abortion he's criticizing premarital sex
like of all people he's gonna you know
it's like it's completely mad but here
it is here's how he made his album is
called Jesus's King and it's basically a
gospel album and he said the reason why
he called it Jesus
so that now everybody on every TV
channel and every every one of these
liberal media outlets when they talk
about his album they have to say Jesus
is king you can't avoid it so he's
playing a trick he's he's still acting
in the guise of a pool he's he's playing
a trick on people but it's turning in
the other direction so in order in order
to understand in order to understand
folly and never understand the pool we
have to we have an intuitive grasp of
the pool but we have to look at the
shape of the world we have to look at
how things are laid out in the world in
the stories to understand what is the
position of the pool why why do we have
this um and so to understand that we
have to think about we have to go back
we always have to go back into the first
story in the first story everything is
packed into that story of creation in
Genesis everything is there we can go
back into that story we find the we find
all the keys to to understanding it and
so in the first story we have these
people Adam and Eve who are in a garden
and traditionally we have to understand
the garden as a mountain very important
to understand it as a mountain in
Scripture it's actually described as a
mountain in Ezekiel and so here they are
on in this mountain that's a garden and
they are innocent and they are nude in
their innocence but they don't know that
they're nude and so the Church Fathers
talk about how they are clothed in glory
because of their innocence in their in
their nudity then of course they fall
they get chased away from the garden and
they move out and then they get these
garments of skin right they get they get
these things that are added to them and
the garments of skin have to be
understood as anything that we add to us
I mean it's not just our clothes but
it's all civilization you know after
that there's Cain build cities they
develop technology they
develop music all of these things are
all these thick these added things that
we added to our natures
to compensate for this fall for this
loss of innocence so now we have this
sense that we have this this structure
this this world that is you know society
civilization all of this and to lose
your clothing now right is shameful so
to be naked it's to be shameful it's not
the same as the nakedness in the garden
right so you have the nakedness in the
garden which is clothed in glory then
you have clothing and then you have this
nakedness that is being a [ __ ] like that
you find yourself in shame and we see it
in the very story of Scripture we have
Adam and Eve we have the fall we have
the flood and right after the flood if
everybody remembers their Bible what
happens right after the flood so Noah
gets drunk disrobes and then he is
shamed for disrobing in his tent right
so there's a structure there it's it's
an actual it's a narrative structure so
you can see the world like that and so
if you if you look at the drunkenness of
Noah that's drunkenness is a is a tag
for foolishness I hope that makes sense
I don't want to explain it too much but
you can understand that
just some when you drink what do you do
you become foolish you just act foolish
you start making jokes you start saying
stupid things you start saying things
that don't they don't make sense and so
the drunkenness and the foolishness are
are together so we have this this
structure now the structure is not just
in it's not just in time intense sense
of a story but also in space so if you
understand the medieval Maps I'm going
to show you this medieval map
so at the top of the map like a mountain
you have the Garden of Eden
I don't know if you can kind of guess
where that is so you see there's a tree
and there's Adam and Eve that are there
can you kind of see it all right
everybody can see that all right and so
then so that the top of the world and
you see these four rivers that are
coming down that's the that's the center
then out of that there's all
civilization all the world the world is
all there all the cities all the
countries all the all these garments of
skin right all these cities and and
civilizations that are added and then on
the fringe of the map
that's where you have all the monsters
right all the exceptions all the things
that don't fit right all the freaks all
the things that aren't what you've know
and so the monsters are represented in
all kinds of ways cannibals
men with with faces in their chests you
know men with just one leg anything any
of any idiosyncrasy right so you can
imagine it as the world of idiosyncrasy
so you have an identity in the top of
the garden and then you have it plays
itself out and on the edge of that you
have the idiosyncrasies and that that's
a rule that's the shape of the world in
terms of how the medieval is understood
the world but it's the shape of every
single identity so you have the Greeks
had the same vision they had the idea
that they were the Greeks that's this
they had their identity and as you moved
out from them you would start to see
things that you don't recognize and you
started to see idiosyncrasies and you
start to see things that don't fit and
then finally on the edge we had the
monster all right so what do i do sync
receives make us do usually now we're
not allowed to but traditionally
idiosyncrasies made people laugh write
things that are normal things that are
strange things that are not usual are
one of the aspects of what would make
someone laugh and ultimately to you on
the edge of the world you also have
upside-down behavior you have for
example for the Greeks you have the
Amazons right the Amazons are the
upside-down world where the women are
the Warriors and the men are not
involved in managing society so it's
like everything is turned upside down
and they live on the edge of the world
right okay can you kind of see it you
have you have rule identity plays itself
out and then on the edge you have these
idiosyncrasies now a lot of you're
wondering like what is that through the
pole you'll see and at the bottom of
course would we have the very outside of
the world
we have dragons so that's the absolute
chaos there on the edge so you can
understand it like this understand it as
a person not just as a map or as in time
you can understand it as the the idea
that you have a highest aspect to you
you could say Christ in you or you could
say your soul there you could say that
the highest aspect of you Christ in your
heart
you know like Saint Paul talks about
this this notion and then on the on the
other ass on the outside of that you
have reason and you have logic you have
knowledge all these other aspects which
are which are you know which we engage
the world with and then that breaks down
into foolishness when knowledge breaks
down when wisdom breaks down we can we
can see this foolishness so the same
structure in terms of space in terms of
a person is this idea of an identity
something that makes you you and then
all the things you do all your
activities all of this and then on the
edge of your being you have the
possibility of this breaking down into a
kind of madness or a kind of folly right
so that's just how that's just how the
world works and on that that part that
comes right up to madness or to folly is
just it's like right on the edge of
death and it's on the edge of death
because if you have any identity the
Greeks for example the further you go
from the Greeks the last three you see
and at some point there's no Greek left
and then the Greeks are dead but they're
dead in space there's no more Greeks as
they're there they're gone the grid or
more Greeks and so it's the same for you
you have you and then you have the
possibility of extending into the world
but at some point there's a limit and
that's your death right and that's
all of these images of the garments of
skin all of these images have to do with
this idea of death that is around us
okay so I hope that makes sense and it's
important to understand I know it seems
very abstract but as I start to show you
the actual foolish things you're gonna
start to understand why I'm talking
about it this way and so it's the face
of a church it's the same structure as a
church church has the same structure we
have the medieval church especially had
the altar in the center where only few
could go only the priest could go then
you had the nave where all the faithful
would gather and all the different types
of people would all interact together
and then you had the narthex which was
like this transition space and what do
you have on the outside you have the
gargoyle to have the monsters you have
the idiosyncracies and a lot of the
gargoyles were exactly idiosyncracies
they were foolish they were silly they
were upside down there there's a lot of
gargoyles that I probably couldn't even
show here because there was actually a
lot of lewdness and some of them some of
these gargoyles because that's it that's
the folly that's on the edge okay so the
shape of the church itself was like that
so now that can help us to understand
the already we can start to also see the
the role of the fool in terms of
positive usually the fool actually has a
very negative role right because the
fool bothers the fool will will make you
laugh you can imagine a situation where
there's something here is happening then
there is a fool someone who makes a joke
when they're not supposed to it
distracts you from work right it
distracts you from what you're supposed
to do that's what laughter does laughter
is a laughter is a loss of control if
you don't if you can get someone to
laugh it's usually they didn't plan on
doing it right you catch them you
surprise them and then they start
laughing and they've lost control right
it's a loss of your being in a way but
there's a way in which the fool can be
very positive because sometimes that
middle part that civilization part
sometimes it's thinks it thinks that it
has it all right Tower of Babel style it
thinks that it has the whole thing it's
got it it's got it we've got it we've
got the rules you've got the structures
we've got but this is how it works and
it just plays out right but that's not
the reality it doesn't work that way
right that's called pride and the pool
the positive aspect of the pool is that
the fool can disrobe the King right the
fool will show you the Kings nakedness
because the the King thinks that his
clothing is all-powerful so it is a kind
of disrobing but sometimes the disrobing
can be good sometimes it can be bad it
just depends and so in our in our
tradition in Christianity but also in
the Bible there are inversion festival
those are the hardest for people to
understand people don't understand and a
lot and a lot of times people really
work hard at trying to eliminate them
even today there's something about the
desire to eliminate them which probably
makes is part of the bigger story but
the the first inversion festival that we
see is in the Bible it's Purim it's the
the celebration of the deliverance of
the Jews from in the story of Esther
everybody knows the story of Esther
Esther is hidden she's secretly a Jew
nobody knows and then she's married to
this foreign King and the foreign King
is being influenced to kill the Jews and
then finally through her revealing
herself as being Jewish to the King and
telling him about this plot then the
story flips and instead of the Jews
being killed
it's the the men who were accusing them
that's what's up it's a turning okay so
you have to understand this is important
to captain just you have to understand
this this wheel this world as a giant
wheel and it's also turning and on the
edge imagine the imagine the world as a
big wheel with the spoke in the center
and the further you go out toward the
edge the faster turns
and that's why we'll see as you've
noticed carnival all carnival esthetic
all that is all about turning it's all
Ferris wheels and you know clowns doing
cartwheels or whatever it's all about
turning right the whole thing is about
turning oh also I forgot to tell you
that the medieval manuscript also had
the exact same structure so medieval
manuscripts had the text in the center
and then on the outside of the text
there was ornamentation and they're
what's called marginalia where all the
freaky stuff would happen so in the
marginality you'd have all this stuff
you'd have you know like not as I mean
it's just nonsense stuff you'd have
rabbits on snails with human heads and
and this is these are these are these
could be Gospels by the way these could
be book of hours it could be prayer
books yeah I saw recently I was shown at
like 14th century prayer book and it was
it was an image of the Annunciation and
in the border there was some wild stuff
going on like that some crazy inversion
okay and a lot of it has to do with
animals or it has to do with animals
taking the role of humans you see that
it you can understand it in terms of the
garments of skin too in terms of this
animality that is on the edge of the
Garden of Eden and that we add to our
nature right upside-down world where the
animals are human and the human are seen
as animals or below the animals okay
I hope you recognize some of these
patterns if you look around today it's
pretty much all we see the idea that
human beings are lower than the animals
it seems to be something a trope that is
is really pervasive in our society
all right so here's the tradition here's
a contemporary version of Purim so the
Jews still celebrated for him today and
traditionally there's a saying that on
forum you are supposed to drink so much
that you cannot tell the difference
between your left hand and your right
hand this is like a traditional practice
and so traditional practicing Jews who
all year are extremely serious and study
the Torah on one day a year will wear
costumes will you know disguise
themselves would get drunk in the
streets will be merrymaking and all this
stuff is going on let's wait here for
now so in our in our in the Catholic
tradition in the the Western tradition
there used to be a feast called the
Feast of Fools and the Feast of Fools
was on January 1st in France and then I
was told it was on January 5th in
England
probably it changed in different
different times and the Peace of fools
was an upside-down feast where they
would take a beggar or they would take
someone very lowly and they would they
raise them up and crown him king or make
him a bishop and they would make fun of
the the liturgy they would make fun of
all these things and it's like I hope
it's important that you feel I I see
some people feeling very uncomfortable
when I say that and you should be it's
ok it's ok to feel uncomfortable about
it but it's also it's also important to
understand that these these really were
things that that were part of our of the
tradition we still have people still
have that today right
we have Mardi Gras Mardi Gras is very
similar Mardi Gras just before Lent you
know all over the world people wear
costumes they it's very gaudy they do
all kinds of merrymaking noise making
right noise is the same example as you
want to understand the same structure I
gave you you have the notion of a
breakdown of logic or a breakdown of
order in terms of speaking what would
that be
the noise noise is the breakdown of
order it's another version of the same
thing
so you have people ratchets and you know
all kinds of stuff to make a lot of
noise that is also part of the of the
carnival setting um and there was also
in the in the West there's also
something called a piece of the ass
which was on January 14th and it was on
the day that they celebrated the the
pleading to - to Egypt when when Mary
and Joseph lead to Egypt and in that
celebration they would bring a donkey up
to the altar and the donkey would be up
Sheep altar and at the end of mass
instead of saying Amen everybody would
Braille iechyd Anki all right okay all
right so this is this is imagery from
the Feast of Fools if you want to see a
really good representation of the Feast
of Fools in the movie The Hunchback of
notre-dame the Disney version they they
have a whole scene in it where they have
the Feast of Fools there and everything
in it is perfect in terms of they show
these upside-down they they show these
upside-down characters they show a horse
with two rear ends they show like a
joker and a king that are kind of
flipping and the ones the kings like is
one side of the king one side of the
Joker so you have this turning and this
turning and this merrymaking and this
noise this kind of this chaos and then
they they take Quasimodo who is
considered to be like a freak in that
society and they elect him king of fools
keep king of the day of the fools and so
he he celebrated but then then he is
humiliated and they they they they
stripped him they humiliate him but they
kind of it thinks they bring things back
to the - - to the order now
here's carnival everybody seen this
Mardi Gras
we still have that today what's the last
inversion festival we have does anybody
anybody identify it in our society we do
no you're not allowing my son you're not
a debate anybody can recognize the last
inversion festival that we have we still
celebrated Halloween Halloween is the
last one right and so it's a it's a it's
an it's a world of upside down where the
monsters are out of the streets and the
these the ghosts are out all of these
marginal characters all these freaks all
these monsters are all out everybody's
wearing costumes everybody's in disguise
there's a kind of praise of idiosyncrasy
and it's happening before our very eyes
and so it's the last it is really the
last inversion festival we also have
carnivals travelling fairs all of this
stuff which you have a traveling fair
come to your town where do they set up
they see you leave set up in a vague
area like a place that's not obviously
they have to set up in the big area
place it that that isn't used that is
kind of a useless place or an abandoned
place a place not a vandal but like a
place that's not functioning so they can
access that place and all the aesthetics
of the carnival are exactly everything
of the Faire exactly what I'm talking
about right the merry-go-round is the
best one because you have animals on the
outside that are turning right and you
have the spoke in the middle and you
have this music and it's all gaudy and
it's all ornaments you know all of this
that all these ornaments on the outside
of the medieval manuscript here they are
in glory in the turning carousel with
all these animals on the outside all
right and we're riding it and we're
laughing it's all there right and of
course we have Las Vegas
this sound in the middle of nowhere that
has no function that has no purpose
except to be a repository for our worst
desires for all our worst passions all
in light and gaudiness
and of course the giant Ferris wheel has
to be there as well now let's go back
over those holidays that I just told you
all right I need to go back over them
because like I could see people kind of
going home I good it's so good to talk
like it this is our world like we're
drowning in it and we're so gorge with
it why are you telling us about these
crazy fools because our whole world is
is just like a big fluffy cake that
people are gorging on it's like our
entire world is that so I understand why
it's like you're like on that again why
are you talking about that well we have
to understand it because that's our
world we have to understand how it plays
out because we're living in the in a
non-stop carnival right this is our
world so we need to get it and we need
to understand the relationship between
carnival and death because it's right
there and all the holidays that I that I
showed you
ah when's Mardi Gras what comes right
after Mardi Gras
the next day Ash Wednesday what Ash
Wednesday it's exactly that it's death
the remembrance of death the ash from
the previous year are brought up and put
up on our foreheads and we remember
death in the Orthodox tradition our our
carnival our meat Fair is on the sunday
of the Last Judgement same day so we
have this celebration this kind of this
kind of celebration of the flesh at the
same time this judgement that comes and
cuts it off okay
Feast of Fools
you want to know why why few suppose was
January 1st January 1st is the eighth
day of Christmas what happened on the
eighth day of Christmas circumcision so
cutting off the flesh the same thing as
Mardi Gras the same thing same pattern
right and the piece of the ass is a
little harder to understand but it's
also the same because the Feast of the
ass is the going to Egypt and you really
it's hard if you don't understand
biblical typology it's gonna be harder
for you to understand but going to Egypt
is always going into death right it's
the land of the foreigner and that's why
Esther marries a foreigner it's also the
same story the idea of marrying a
foreigner is losing your identity right
your identity is moving out right and
you're and you're here you're moving out
into to that and it's not it's neither
good nor bad like it sometimes it's good
you see end up in the Bible there are
places where it's you know Moses his
wife was Ethiopian like it's not it's
not a moral question but we have to
understand the the structure we have to
understand that that's what's going on
right this idea of moving out of
yourself and that's and that is related
to death all right
and Halloween is exactly the same right
Halloween
what comes after Halloween what is
Halloween the eve of All Hallows and
then it says the eve of All Souls is the
eve of those celebrations and the
remembrance of all the dead right so
it's all it's all the same pattern it
just always plays itself out the same
now the problem today right that all
those people that are going through
Mardi Gras and Brazil or wherever they
are they're probably not fasting after
that and all the people who celebrate
Halloween are not doing the other part
right and like I said our world is it is
the carnival is the last celebration we
have but we have to understand what it
leads to it does lead to death there's
no way around it that's what the
Carnival leads to that that's it even
it's almost its role is to show us the
limit and to show us death okay all
right so hopefully now this is making a
little bit more sense to you
understanding why I'm talking about this
all right so this structure is is
everywhere okay it's every once you
understand it once you see it you're
going to start to see it appear in many
places okay when you start to understand
this relationship so I'm gonna give you
an example that you maybe never ever
ever have thought of and it's the it's
it's it's the last night of Christ in
the Garden of Gethsemane there's a joke
in that story do you ever notice there's
a joke in that story right I'll show you
the joke there is a joke there so we
have a mountain remember the part
paradise is a mountain we have a
mountain and then the disciples are down
below Christ goes up to pray up the
mountain he goes into the Garden of Eden
he's going up to the tree of trees the
to the trees it's going into the garden
right he's going on to pray and he
leaves the disciples below and what does
he tell the disciples wake up stay awake
remember
right remember as you move as you're far
away from me and as you're far away from
the center
remember the center remember the garden
don't forget the garden but what do they
do they fall asleep
what is falling asleep it's dying
falling asleep is always dying falling
asleep in Scripture is always dying okay
so they die then Christ comes back down
and it's like we got wake up what are
you doing you have to remember you have
to remember and then they don't and it
happens three times and it's already I
mean it's already calling out to
something else and finally here comes
the foreigners foreigners come the
Romans come and they're going to destroy
this thing here's Christ the twelve
disciples they come and they scatter the
Apostles everything's broken and while
they're doing that what happens where's
the joke as one of the disciples is
running away one of the Roman soldiers
grabs his clothing and he runs away
naked right okay all right that's that's
it that's the same thing everything that
I'm telling you this is the same same
thing same system same structure okay
now
now the problem with this it's not the
helter-skelter it's not the church it's
that the helter-skelter is in the church
that's a problem it you the problem is
not the fact that these things on the
edge are there that's part of the
structure of reality the problem is
where do you put them where are they
this does not belong this belongs in the
carnival does that belong in a church
we've lost our capacity to see the
hierarchies of things one of the
problems is that because we don't
understand let's say where this type of
thing belongs then we don't know how to
react when you see it in a church is
like well you know God wants us to be
happy and wants us to laugh and God
wants us to be merry so why not have a
spinning slide down you know no snakes
and ladders
there's that snake going down it's
basically there's an image of the Last
Judgement in the eye can the iPad in the
Orthodox tradition where there's a snake
which goes all the way down from Christ
into hell and there it is right there
it's like who's sliding down all right
sorry I'm gonna stop being sarcastic
here for a second all right all right so
now this is all that's left
right the Carnival is all that's left in
our culture you can understand it that
way too right you have white light and
it breaks down too many colors there
Winnie ways many ways to represent the
very same structure and that's it that's
our world right now how do we how does
it flip that how does it how does the
fool play the role because a lot of you
a lot of you love English I've you read
Shakespeare we we were talking about
this and how in Shakespeare plays and a
lot of tropes you have the fool who
reveals the truth the fool who actually
reveals the thing the secret
or the thing that other people are
hiding right that only happens in it
only happens in an upside-down world
because the pool is turning the pool is
turning and then when things are upside
down he's not gonna stop turning when
things are upside down he's just gonna
he's just gonna turn them right side up
so we have to watch the pools especially
right now I would tell people watch the
pools because when you see something
like Kanye West what happened they're
like that's exactly the type of thing
that you're going to see happen more and
more these foolish characters that are
going to flip and going to bring back
kind of this normal order by doing it so
the key the key to to starting to
understand this is in the story of King
David King David is the one of the
clearest places where you see this start
to flip now this is the secret right
this is the secret that Christ is
ultimately going to reveal to us which
is that if in the garden glory was
changed into death right the nakedness
of Adam and Eve was changed into an
image of death then death can be changed
into glory
right and that's you'll see that's what
Christ is doing Christ is turning the
world back off taking the fall
flipping it on its head right taking
everything of the fall and bringing it
bring it in a way that actually works
towards our salvation we start to see
that a little bit in the story of King
David a lot of people don't know the
story of King David because it's so
crazy that people actually pretend that
they know the story of King David but
it's a crazy story this arcing ariza
story of King David seriously it is wild
King David is is the fool who became a
king and you see it in his story he
there there's a scene there's a scene in
his story where he acts insane there's a
scene in his story where he pretends to
be working for the foreign army there's
a scene in that story in his story where
also he marries other people's wives
right all his wives are other people's
wives so he's marrying a foreign woman
the one that Solomon is warning you not
to marry like David marries those women
but for some reason there's something
about his character that is able to clip
that into something else the wildest
story of King David is the one where you
can almost you can see it the clearest
and I'm sorry that I'm gonna have to
talk about this but we you did come to
the talk that had the word fool in it so
we're gonna have to talk about this so
there is a story where King Saul is on
going on the road and he has to stop he
has to stop he's got to go and so his
men are like what do you do and so he
goes down into a cave now what is going
down into a cave
it's like sleeping going down if the
cave is dying it's already dying okay so
so King stall goes down into this cave
to do his business in the scripture they
call it covering his feet that's how
they called it tried I want to think
about it too much but so turns out David
is in the cave David's in the cave and
so he sees the the king there doing his
thing
so he sneaks up behind him and he cuts a
part of his cloth and he just cuts the
caught a part of the fringe of
assessment and he keeps it right so then
King Saul you know gets out of the cave
and then David brandishes the fringe of
assessment okay now you really have to
understand what this is really trying to
show you like he's ranting the French
he's brandishing the thing on the edge
and he's showing it to Saul and he's
basically disrobing the King that's what
he's doing right he's taking a piece of
his clothing
he's showing he's humiliating the King
he's he's showing the Kings nakedness to
everybody and it's all finally let's go
Saul lets him go and ultimately King
David will end up replacing the king he
will rise up and become the king but you
see that structures right there I hope
you can you see it but it's the same
there's the nakedness there's this this
in shame you would call it right there
shame there's nakedness and there's this
moment where he actually takes it and he
shows him like here's your thing right
so like sorry but so we have the poop
emoji which is everywhere that's our
world the poop emoji is our world we
have to understand it okay if you want
to understand the poop emoji why it
would be happening right now and it
would be everywhere is because is if you
understand these stories you can
understand why it's happening you won't
be surprised you can see it as a problem
in our society but you won't be totally
surprised that
you come to the edge of the world one of
the things that's going to happen is
going to be scatological references and
those are going to D be comfor vasive in
your society just inevitable right it's
the fringe showing itself all right all
right so all right so the next story I'm
going to tell you one more story about
King David and then and then we'll get
something else the other story of King
David which really really shows this
pattern and how it flips is the story of
him and the arc everybody knows the
story right so David danced before the
Lord with all his might and David was
wearing an ethic
do you know what an ephod is right an
ephod is a is a is a cloth and you don't
know how exactly was used it had stones
on it but it was used for casting Lots
was a tool of divinization of like like
you know like throwing bones like you
see in the throw bones and read the
bones that's what that the ephod was for
it was it was a tool of divination of
divination to know the will of God right
and so he's wearing a so you have to you
have to understand again one of the
things that the breakdown of order looks
like is lots right because if you get
money usually because you work there's a
way to break that is you chance go to
Las Vegas right
give yourself into the wheel of fortune
this turning wheel and then maybe that
wheels gonna put you on top who knows
you don't know it slots it doesn't make
sense it's not part of the read it's not
part of reason to break down of reason
okay that's what Lots are and so he's
wearing this effort and it seems like
he's disrobe somehow like he's maybe
just wearing the effort we don't know
like it it seems like he's disrobe that
he's dancing he's merrymaking in front
of the arc now people will tell you
Karris Mattox will use this diverted
use this verse to to justify their thing
but if you know the story you realize
that this is very exceptional that this
is exactly this weird moment of turning
when the fool is going to become the
king and so you have this turning moment
where he acts the fool in front of the
arc he's wearing this this this effort
that's used for for for casting Lots and
so the daughter of Saul says what looked
read the language read the language so
she says how glorious was the king of
Israel today uncovering himself today in
the eyes of the maids and his servants
as one of the base fellows shamelessly
uncovers himself okay so she's being
ironic she's saying the opposite of what
she's saying right now that's important
because you that's a joke right that's
that's a clown that's that's our world
irony right if when order breaks down
one of the things that happens is that
when you say something it's the opposite
and there's this strange relationship of
meaning which is not direct it's kind of
indirect upside down turning of what
you're saying and what is she saying
she's saying how glorious was the king
remember what I told you about Adam and
Eve in the garden being naked
what was it for them it was glory and
now she's making fun of him she's saying
you're you were making your tough
Laura's by uncovering yourself but she's
ultimately saying shame like a shameless
person you're you're you're full of
shame by doing this but here's this is
the flip that's happening her irony is
actually turning back on itself and it
is to his glory it is to David's glory
that he was doing that so you've got
something she's turning it upside down
and it's turning back right-side up can
you see it in the statement
okay so this is that this is it this is
the thing turning upside down and then
the fool can turn it right-side up this
is a this is a perfect example of this
now ultimately this will lead us to this
story particular leads us to Christ
because that's exactly what happened to
Christ that's exactly what happened to
Christ right Christ was disrobed he was
humiliated
he was ironically declared king but what
happened turn back right that crown of
thorns became a crown of glory turn back
and you have to understand this is very
profound because the crown of thorns
that's the result of the fall God said
to Adam and Eve if when you fall the
world will produce thorns was the very
result of their sin was this hostile
exterior right this exteriority that has
spikes on it that can hurt you and then
Christ turned that turn the very result
of the fall into glory so everything
they said about him
when they said hail the king when they
put that sign above his head to say the
king of the Jews they were end and in
the end they were actually telling the
truth it was turning upside down twice
making it ironic and then flipping back
right-side up right and so that's the
ultimate fool the ultimate role of the
pool and we see Christ embodying that
role perfectly where the the disrobing
of shame gets turned into the glory of
paradise and you have to you have to
understand so much of our tradition so
much of Christianity is about that and
if we don't understand it
then we look like we at some point we
don't know what to say when someone
tells us like what's great about some
guy getting eaten by a lion in a in a
you know in the circus in Rome like you
think that's great that's not great
that's stupid it's horrible it's
horrible that you would get eaten by a
lion in Rome and get desecrated and
humiliated and all that if we don't
understand how that turn happens then
we're not going to be able to understand
our own traditions right why is it that
we think that to be to be humble you
know and to to to to accept humiliation
is good that's that that's the game that
happening right
so when you see characters like Saint
Francis and it's interesting because
there's a trope right now of people
wanting to say that he was you know the
troubadour for Christ that he was the
fool for Christ and you see the same
thing Saint Francis does the same thing
where the sent Francis do when he
embraces his his mission he disrobe
himself right and the thing that's
really important to understand it's it's
really important to understand for us as
traditional Christians is also not to
confuse those extremes either most
people who disrobe themselves in public
are not holding fools okay and we really
have to be able to tell the difference
because seriously we're in a world that
is so mad that that that people might
say that a stripper is like is like it's
like our Saints all right so if we the
world is crazy enough that it can happen
we have to be able to tell the
difference between the two okay
and so when we look at at these at these
these figures like these turns these
fools that are now somehow wanting to
show us reality or bring back order we
shouldn't be surprised it's going to
happen more and more and we need to as
the world devolves more and more into
this world of kind of mad carnival it's
actually the fools that are going to
that are going to turn it back
we need to pay attention to see who are
those those holy pools and not just
regular pools so so I I think I think
I've said enough I hope that this was
food for thought I think we're going to
do like I think we're going to do
dessert first and then and then if you
have some questions please write them
down on the piece of paper that you have
in front of you you can drop them in to
this bin over here and hopefully those
questions won't be too difficult for me
so this is diffic talking about pools is
very tricky you know so thank you all
right and so the first question is do
you intend to wear your bow tie
as future speaking engagements very
curious where that question comes from I
don't know I would have to I'm afraid
that when I it's like you know things at
Saskatoon stay in Saskatoon that I think
when I go back home it's kind of like
Las Vegas but it's Eska - all right
ok so I could be convinced though we'll
see who knows why do you why do you
suggest we should watch for the pools
who can leverage their effects help them
lift things up right again or only for
our interest and enjoyment I think that
I mean the case that I'm talking about
it's really so that we can notice the
moments where our culture is turning
towards at least hope ultimately turning
towards Christ turning right side up and
so that we can also bolster that we can
encourage that and help that that is my
you know because the fool can't do it
can't do it on his own the fool will
just the fool will just operate the flip
but usually the pool is not the one
that's gonna build things afterwards
there are exceptions like I said the the
greatest fools that's what they do you
know the King David is exactly that he
he he he he was the pool but he also
brought the ark to Jerusalem and then
planned the temple and st. Francis was
told to rebuild the church so it's there
is the
in the possibility but most of the time
we'll need to get things going around
the pools in 2006 there was a film of
Russian language called the island it
was a moderate portrayal of the holding
pool what are your thoughts on the
Russian tendencies of honor of holy
pools have you seen the film yes I have
seen the film
I really recommend it it's a great movie
you can I think you can even find it for
free on YouTube you know for the island
the island or Ostrow of I think in
Russian and it is a really wonderful
story and you really do see the the role
that the pool does in in shaming people
into let's say you know into repentance
something like that and it's definitely
worth seeing there's also a book called
loris that was written recently by a
Russian author that deals with the story
of a holy pool and in that story if you
read the story you'll see that the
author is extremely not understand the
tropes himself because he'll talk about
these monstrous races on the edge of the
world he talks about Alexander the Great
building a wall you know in the northern
in the northern world to stop these
monsters from coming in so he seems to
really understand the relationship
between the pool and these other stories
and other tropes that are there it's
called Loras la you are us do you think
that there's hope we will have more
saints pools who will help to turn this
crazy world upside down or right set up
I think so I do think that we're already
seeing it happen and I think it's it's
going to happen more and more as the
world becomes more and more mad than
then the fools will be the ones that
will kind of show us a way out so need
to pay attention need to be careful
because some of the pools are just
fooled we have to be really careful
because in a world of folly it is
sometimes hard to discern the the holy
pool but the holy pool is flipping
that's what he's doing he is flipping
things he's working to the salvation of
others do you know if anyone has written
a theology of humor if not have you
considered writing one I don't know if
someone has written a theology of humor
imagine if they did it would probably
not be very how can I say this would
probably be very subversive honestly
especially in our modern day and age I
don't think I would write a book like
that but if you want I have several
talks that on my youtube channel that
addressed that I have a talk called the
end of the world and the purpose of
laughter where I talk about some of the
similar things that I talk about here
and expand on on different aspects of it
is there a role for us then in being
fools to set the system right or a
critique it or is this a specialist role
I would suggest did not play that role
because it's a very dangerous thing to
do and it's very dangerous for your soul
and it's very dangerous it's a very
dangerous thing the holy pool is a very
dangerous character he's that he is you
know if you read the book Loras it's
really worth reading because you really
do see this holy pool and you see that
no you don't want that life like you
don't want to be the to accept being the
butt of the joke because that's the
thing you could the one of the ways
maybe you can see the difference between
pool that is useful and a pool that is
not useful is the fool that is that is
not useful usually it's just making fun
of other people and the fool that is
useful usually that turns then back on
himself right and so the proper clown
will will tricky be tricking people but
on the end he slips on his own banana
peel and he falls like that the proper
clown that's the clown that actually the
full turn clown okay
a lot of the foolishness that we see
around in the world right now is
actually is actually extremely kind of
like this angry foolishness that is once
you accuse that wants to accuse the
system you know being the oppressor of
doing all that and all of this and all
this but the the real fool or the full
full fool doesn't doesn't do that
doesn't accuse the system he makes fun
of it and then it turns and he realized
that well he's actually can't avoid
being part of it so it turns back on him
there are several cultures like in them
Native American cultures day
have these these fools as part of their
actual rituals like that The Fool is
actually has a function in in the
especially in the desert Native
Americans in the u.s. that the desert
the plain Indians they had and called
the hikoi which was this this character
that with in ritual would come to the
rituals and would would pass gas and
would like start saying stupid things
like just to distract he was acting in a
way to show the limit of the of the
ritual to say this ritual is it
all-encompassing and so you have that
but they never they're not there to
destroy the ritual they're just there to
show the limit of the ritual right to
show that it doesn't encompass
everything anyways do you have any
advice to help us recognize the holy
pool versus a regular pool I think
that's that's that's a big one in terms
of accepting to be to be humble is one
of the biggest aspects that you'll see
in a holding pool and and like I said it
usually ends up turning things it's hard
because you you it's so popular right
now to criticize Authority like
everybody does it it's just it just it's
become normal to come it's come normal
to criticize Authority so the holy fool
would probably end up doing something
different would criticize criticizing
Authority or something like that and
then it would turn so I don't know when
I see it I like when I see when I can
point you to him like I think I think
Kanye West is playing a role that's
clothing close to it like the way that
he's he's he's flipping everything and
the way he's doing it is very kind of
funny also because he's just the idea of
naming his album Jesus is king and
knowing what it's gonna do and for some
people to say it you know it's kind of
humorous but it's a it does what it does
alright King Cyrus was not a believer in
the God of Israel yet he was prophesized
two hundred years before he was
instrumental in the return of Israel
from captivity what's he a fool
no I don't think that I don't think that
in this case he would be considered a
fool
there there is a figure there's a figure
in storytelling which is kind of the you
know in them how can I say this there
are several there's not risking stars
even the king in the story of Esther
also plays a role similar to the King
Cyrus which is the good it's like the
good foreigner who helps to bring back
order but it's not necessary he doesn't
necessarily act in the same way of a
fool it's not it's not it's a little
similar because he's a foreign King so
he's not part of us he's this thing
outside and he's saying he's Keith
helping to restore that which is inside
um in the story of Elijah you have that
quite a bit
Elijah does Elijah is called the
stranger his name his name the lives of
the fizzbin means Elijah the stranger
and he's coming from and he's coming as
a stranger no we're in an upside-down
world anyway but it's not exactly like
before it is similar though it's a good
insight that you had River wrote that in
Russia they used the term holy fool
wasn't it just a common mentally
deranged person who happened to exist in
the community that was referred to how
does this relate no I don't think so I
don't think that it's just a mentally
deranged person that happened to exist I
think that there are tropes about the
holy pools that might look like that you
see the stories of people pretending to
be crazy and you in into hagiography
where they pretend to be crazy and then
someone catches them and they're in like
you know in their house and they're
they're praying or they're being
completely normal you know and so you
have this idea of pretending and playing
now is it possible that someone who is
mentally ill could play the same role as
a holy pool for a community I think so I
think so because one of the reason why
we have exceptional people people who
are mentally ill or people who are
handicapped in certain ways we're even
mentally mentally handicapped is also to
show us the limit of our reason to show
us that we don't income we don't we
think that being able being smart being
all this is all but it's not you know
and you see sometimes you see people who
are mentally handicapped have this like
beautiful innocent joy that is just
amazing and they're the ones were
supposed to be lower on the hierarchy
but in the end they have this kind of
glorious real life in them and so I
think they can play the role and show us
the limits of our of our work of our of
our structures because they have this
innocence so I think they can place them
to rope it's not exactly the same I
don't think so um is Trump a figure of
the fool
[Music]
there's related it's definitely related
it's hard not to see that it's related
just his name it's hard not to think
that the Joker card is the trump card so
it's not completely unrelated I don't
know it's hard to tell like he's I say
the jury's still out on him I would say
it that way so where does Satan fit in
all of this I don't know I mean I think
Satan Satan is is is the hmm I mean
Satan is the one who opposes is the one
who divides and so you could see Satan
as the one of the causes of this fall of
his breakdown and everything but sorry
yeah
then it turns back on him VG exactly
yeah that's a good call father yes I saw
those we didn't hear it
he said Satan what Satan does is he
accuses but it never turns back on him
and so he does plays that role of
criticizing the authority but it he's
not able to see himself also as the butt
of the joke and so he doesn't end up
playing this role of the it is not the
case that ever since the fall of man who
in kind has been in a state of Carnival
in what respect are our times different
no I don't think so
III think I think that there are cycles
and that there if you read in scripture
you see that there are these cycles
where where God reveals himself and God
pulls people together pulls Israel
together and creates this this image of
the glorious City let's say a little
image of this final possibility of all
things coming together so you have these
moments where this happens and then it
kind of falls apart so it's like you see
these cycles in the story where it moves
from like holy times - it's kind of
broken down times and then these upside
down times and so you see that you see
these cycles and I think that the fact
that we that we integrate the carnival
in our that traditionally you would
integrate the carnival in that in the in
the normal liturgy and that's something
that I maybe didn't explain very well -
it is the the fact that we also have the
carnival in the pattern of reality is
related to Sabbath somewhat it's related
to the idea of work and then a day of
rest you know and so it's not exactly
the same in the sense that the in let's
say the holiest version of it we
necessarily have this upside-down thing
but Sabbath is a little image of death
you know we can't avoid it that's why
when we talk about Christ's day of the
tomb we say that it's the great Sabbath
and your thark addition we have
many hymns that talk about that this is
the great Sabbath that Christ's day in
the tomb is the is his the say the man
that showing us the group the the glory
of the Sabbath what the Sabbath could be
and so there is a relationship between
this day of rest or this this last day
that doesn't does not work this residue
all these images there's images and
related to I always talk about the idea
that you have to leave a margin and you
see that in Scripture all over the place
where they talk about the fringe of
investment you have to have a fringe on
the edge of something to leave it a
little bit wild you have to leave the
corners of your field don't plow all the
field you need to leave the corners of
your field for the foreigners you know
and it's wrong related to this you have
to you have to leave a little bit of
space for chaos you know and if you
don't if you try to encompass everything
then chaos comes back with a baseball
bat it's like we're done with this and
then the whole world turns into a
carnival one of the reasons why our
world is turned into a carnival is
because we because of modernism it's
because we the Enlightenment thought
that it could encompass everything that
the world of science thought that it
could completely fill up all knowledge
and all understanding but that's not
true there's always a buffer there's
always a margin there's always a residue
there's always a remainder you can't get
rid of it and and and so because they
push so hard to stop this it flipped
back and now everything is remainder
everything is residue everything is is
Carnival right and so we we need to be
careful because as as traditional
Christians we we see they say these
images of of these chaotic things and we
we might feel a little disgusted by it
because we're so surrounded by it that
we're like no we were going to be
traditional Christians we're gonna be we
have order we're gonna have prayer we're
gonna have you know we're gonna have
these these hours and everything we're
going to follow the calendar and all of
this and it and it's important but the
traditional Christians did celebrate
Mardi Gras where the digital Christians
did celebrate these Feast of Fools
because you need it's part of reality
right you just need things to be in
their proper place and need in their
proper measure right that's how that's
how you know that the world is
working you know you know you want
ornaments on the outside of the church
but you don't or you want ornaments but
you don't it's like you you eat
something you can have spice on it but
you don't eat spice but you don't just
shovel spice into your mouth and you
also don't do the same with ornaments
you have ornaments does that decorate a
building but it's a decoration the whole
building can be ornament right can't be
this fringe right so yeah so I think
that's done with those questions I hope
this was useful for people
thanks for coming if you enjoy the
symbolic world content there's a lot of
things you can do to help us out if
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends if
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
[Music]